[Applause]
we're here to tell government
we don't want your benefits we don't
want your welfare
don't come knocking on my door with your
fountain outie
you leave us the hell alone
right like with dr fauci i just recently
were in the process of sending a letter
to the doj
he lied to congress he should be
accountable for lying to congress and
lying
and senator iran
[Applause]
[Applause]
clearly they were hoping the government
was hoping
that they could sort of sucker 90 of the
population into getting vaccinated and
it
and and it and it isn't happening right
there's a
younger people are well aware of what
the risks really are and they're well
aware of the side effect profile
[Music]
thank you it's true we all won
we all want in a matter of mere months
joe biden has brought
our country to the brink of ruin and we
don't need
windmills in texas and lots of other
places
we don't need when they ought to end
that
program as quickly as they can i said
doc how about if i take a cognitive test
he said well you can do it sir but if
you do you know uh
it'll be public well i said what's wrong
with that he said well if you don't do
well sir
it's not gonna be pretty i said is it
hard he said after the first five
questions it gets very hard
i said let's take a shot at it and we
did it and we aced it right i aced it
and one of the doctors said he's never
seen anybody that aced it
and some of those questions are not easy
i will tell you that
so this is gonna be the most racist
[Applause]
in all of dallas this weekend
when i saw the ad that said the nfl is
gay
can you believe they are sexually
perverting our children right now before
our eyes
because they don't believe in individual
thought it's about collective thought
it is exactly what karl marx has been
pushing they never wanted the family to
succeed
it was always about government control
of what you think
what you believe what you can do
because dictatorial socialists want to
cancel america
we have to fight back
to protect our country's greatness i
totally understand addiction it's
terrible
we all know people that have suffered
from it it doesn't absolve you from
being a total piece of garbage in every
other aspect of your life
it doesn't absolve you from selling
access to the highest power levels of
government it doesn't absolutely from
selling out your country
don't laugh you're now canceled
congratulations
by laughing you would have been thrown
off every social media platform you
would have been thrown out of a job in
science
they don't want free and fair elections
they want elections
only democrats can win hey bruce
bruce here we go here we go what do you
think about the stuff that they're
teaching in schools regarding the lgbtq
about jesus christ bruce don't forget
about jesus